I also learned from him that
uh everyone's
afraid because this way of saying
another great saying you'll get kick out
of this uh anyone who's in a situation
where fear should be prevalent where
fear is actually necessary to survive
the situation anyone who says that
they're not afraid they're one of two
things they're either a liar or they
should go to a doctor find out what the
freak's wrong with
them he was right about
that you know we live in a a taboo
Society where that word to a certain
extent is taboo because it invokes
weakness you know we we uh we are just
layers of what we saw and learned since
we were kids we all are we're products
of those layers I learned that on my own
well through some help at the end of the
day
um you
know
fear people will find their way of
avoiding that term so they use the word
anxiety they use the word you know
butterflies apprehension you know yeah
million different right words I find all
those other words to be cousins of fear
and and fear fear causes a lot of things
in life it it causes a lot of problems
uh and and it also solves a lot of
problems without it uh we couldn't be
great if we are great if we ever have a
chance to be great um or at least to
Aspire to be great how how does Fear
connect to Greatness that's a that's a
profound statement without fear we
wouldn't be able to be
great yeah you couldn't be great without
fear
because fear allows her to
be
brave the most important word for me in
this whole you know conversation right
neighborhood would be
selfishness uh it allows you to be for a
moment less
selfish one of the things I learned I
guess partly on my own
everyone thinks my greatest teacher was
cus he was a great teacher but Mentor my
greatest teacher was my father the one
who never
talked and um I realized um one of the
things to be better towards
great um is if you can
be submit less than we submit see one of
the things that I'm afraid of one of the
things I was always
quitting and my business it's kind of
not a good thing mhm every business I
think yours yours is just more uh clear
yeah it it hurts more
and in the moment at least yeah in the
moment you're right 100% because some
things hurt for a long time afterwards
and um something like regret regret is
the worst thing in the world because
it's a solitary sentence and and man oh
man that's a powerful phrase regret is a
solitary sentence so boy I you full of
good
lines you know it wasn't easy to uh to
to accumulate them it was it was a
little bit hurtful but so uh submit less
because we submit every day and if we
can get to a place where we submit or
compromise ourselves
less we we'll get to a better place you
know again one of the one of the words
for me that attaches to things that give
you that wind up hurting you in life and
have hurt me in life uh one of those
boogey men words is the word of
convenience that's attach to everything
you know PE people
people disappoint you not because they
want to disappoint you or let you down
or betray you because they want to
betray you they do it because it's more
convenient to do mhm than than the other
thing